Ці президентські вибори - за багатьма показниками рекордні у постмайданній Україні.
На головну посаду в країні спершу претендували 44 кандидати.
Але згодом п'ятеро зняли кандидатури.
Тож нині лишилися 39 претендентів.
Серед п’яти фаворитів - четверо загалом підтримують інтеграцію до Євросоюзу
Проросійським кандидатом вважають лише Юрія Бойка.
Перший тур голосування відбудеться 31 березня.
Другий - 21 квітня.
Там у двобої зійдуться два лідери перегонів.
Якщо жоден з кандидатів не набере понад 50% голосів у першому турі.
Ім’я нового президента країна має дізнатися протягом 10 днів після другого туру.
В Україні - близько 35 млн виборців.
Проте проголосувати зможуть лише 30 мільйонів.
Решта - або переселенці,
або на окупованих територіях, або закордоном, які не змінили реєстрацію.
Бюлетень у першому турі буде рекордно довгим.
Аж 80 см.
Якщо скласти усі бюлетені, то їхня довжина перевищить 24 тисячі км.
Це відстань від Києва до столиці Уругваю - Монтевідео.
Або площа 70 футбольних полів.
І 434 тонни паперу.
На друк бюлетенів витратять близько 160 млн гривень.
А загалом вибори коштуватимуть понад 2 мільярдигривень.